.
>> OH.
AND THIS GOT OUT OF HAND.
141-126.
AFTER THE GAME, KYRIE, THE
FORMER CELTIC, PLANTING THAT
FOOT ON THE LEPRECHAUN'S FACE.
AND SOMEBODY IN THE STANDS
THROWS A WATER BOTTLE.
THAT CAME VERY CLOSE TO
CONNECTING.
>> I DON'T THINK THE TWO SIDES
ARE CONNECTED.
>> I'M NOT SAYING THERE IS A
CONNECTION.
YOU'RE SAYING KYRIE IRVING, AS
HE LEAVES THE FLOOR, THERE GOES
THE WATER BOTTLE.
AND AUTHORITIES HAVE THEIR MAN.
>> YOU HAD A GOOD POINT EARLIER.
LET THE KID TAKE DOWNSTAIRS AND
LET KYRIE HANDLE IT.
>> I DIDN'T SAY THAT.
>> YOU DID.
>> YES, YOU DID.
MAN UP.
>> SAY WHAT YOU SAY.
DON'T SAY WHAT I SAY.
>> BY THE WAY, T.D. GARDEN
ISSUING A LIFETIME BAN.
>> THAT'S WHAT THEY SHOULD DO
WHEN A FAN DOES THAT.
A LIFETIME BAN.
>> LET'S HEAR FROM K.D. AND
KYRIE ON THE INCIDENT.
>> FANS HAVE TO GROW UP AT SOME
POINT.
I KNOW BEING IN A HOUSE FOR A
YEAR AND A HALF WITH THE
PANDEMIC, GOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
ON-EDGE AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
STRESSED OUT.
WHEN YOU COME TO THE GAMES, YOU
HAVE TO REALIZE, THESE GUYS ARE
HUMAN.
WE'RE NOT ANIMALS.
WE'RE NOT IN A CIRCUS.
YOU COMING TO THE GAME IS NOT
ALL ABOUT YOU AS A FAN.
HAVE SOME RESPECT FOR THE GAME
AND HAVE SOME RESPECT FOR THE
HUMAN BEINGS AND HAVE SOME
RESPECT FOR YOURSELF.
YOU MOTHER WOULDN'T BE PROUD OF
YOU THROWING WATER BOTTLES AT
BASKETBALL PLAYERS OR SPITTING
ON PLAYERS OR TOSSING POPCORN.
GROW THE [ BLEEP ] UP AND ENJOY
THE GAME.
>> PEOPLE FEEL ENTITLED OUT
HERE.
THEY PAY FOR THE TICKETS.
I'M GRATEFUL THEY'RE COMING IN
TO WATCH A GREAT PERFORMANCE.
IT'S TOO MUCH.
IT'S A REFLECTION ON US AS A
WHOLE, WHEN YOU HAVE FANS ACTING
LIKE THAT.
>> WE KNOW HOW PEOPLE ARE HERE
IN BOSTON.
HOW PASSIONATE THEY ARE ABOUT
KYRIE IN.
>> Mary PARTICULAR.
WE DON'T NEED TO SPEAK ON THAT.
WE KNOW WHAT IT, COMING IN HERE.
>> WE KNOW THE VAST MAJORITY OF
NBA FANS AND SPORTS FANS ARE
JUST THAT.
16,999 ACTED ACCORDINGLY.
IT'S NOT A PERCENTAGE.
NOW, I THINK IT'S GETTING TO THE
POINT THEY FEEL THEY WILL GET ON
"SPORTSCENTER" AND TNT AND ON
"INSIDE THE NBA."
SOME OF THAT IS ACCURATE, AS
WELL, THAT BEHAVIOR.
WANTING TO BE SEEN.
>> YOU THINK HE DID THAT --
>> HE DIDN'T WANT TO GET
ARRESTED.
STOP IT.
>> THE CRIMINAL MIND IS
ILLOGICAL FROM THE START.
>> THERE'S PEOPLE THAT WILL DO
THINGS BECAUSE THEY WANT
ATTENTION.
>> YEAH.
>> I CAN SEE IF A GUY RUNS ON
THE FIELD.
>> THIS GUY WAS STUPID.
DON'T GO CRAZY.
WE HAD, I THINK, FOUR INCIDENTS.
AND WE'VE HAD HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF FANS.
THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN FANS THAT
ARE IDIOTS.
THE MAJORITY OF THE FANS ARE
GOOD PEOPLE.
1 GUY OUT OF 17,000 ACTED LIKE
AN IDIOT TONIGHT.
>> I PLAYED -- HOW LONG YOU
PLAY?
>> 16.
>> I PLAYED 19 YEARS.
I SEEN IT BEFORE.
I PLAYED IN THE S.E.C.
I PLAYED HIGH SCHOOL BASKETBALL
IN TEXAS.
I SEEN IT BEFORE.
AND BOTH GUYS MAKE GOOD POINTS.
A LOT OF THE FANS THINK BECAUSE
THEY PAY MONEY, THEY DO WHATEVER
THEY WANT.
IT'S BEEN HAPPENING FOR A LONG
TIME.
THE WATER BOTTLE DIDN'T HIT HIM.
LET'S JUST MOVE ON.
>> THANK YOU.
>> IT WILL CONTINUE TO HAPPEN.
>> LET'S HOPE NOT.
>> ERNIE --
>> IT'S ALWAYS HAPPENING.
IT HAPPENED WHEN ME AND SHAQ
PLAYED.
THERE'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE IDIOT
FA